breaking news author salman rushdie has
been attacked while giving a speech in
western new york
we're going to get uh more on this now
with kristin that's lumi in new york
well kristen uh what do we know so far
well very little the news is just coming
out but uh
a report that was released from
uh the associated press filed by a
reporter who was on the scene described
a man taking stage
with salman rushdie who was giving a
lecture at a
non-profit education center in western
new york
as he took the stage this man according
to witnesses
jumped up there and began attacking him
either punching or stabbing him
and rusty fell to the ground the man was
quickly restrained
and according to unconfirmed reports
that we're seeing on twitter he was able
to walk off stage with assistants after
getting some help
this all comes
many years after rushi
was
made was
released his book uh the satanic verses
which was very controversial that was
back in 1988
uh it was considered blasphemous by many
muslims and banned in several countries
including south africa pakistan
bangladesh and iran
they
had riots in many of those countries as
a result of the book and a year after it
was published iran's
leader
ayatollah khamenei
issued a fatwa against him and a three
million dollar reward was offered for
his death and rushji went into hiding
for 10 years and in recent years he's
come back out in public he has a book
that was due to he has a book that is
due to be released in february uh but
this was a lecture that he's giving at
this educational center and someone
jumped on stage to attack him and really
that's all we know right now but it
appears that he was able to walk off
stage with assistance so
that is
what we know at this point
okay with that breaking news christian
for now thank you